oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Monday November 11 time to get this
[ __ ] party started
whatever you've been hearing it's coming
to an end it's a whole new [ __ ] week
and you [ __ ] you better be ready
to go oh
it's Monday November 11 [ __ ]
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive uncle Joey
coming at you direct and in [ __ ]
color you understand me ready to go tip
top Magoo I always tell you to keep your
eyes open they're almost already tried
to blow up [ __ ] Port Authority this
morning on a Monday morning you follow
i'm santi mondays are the most important
day of the week you make a [ __ ]
statement and they tried to blow up all
authority but that got nothing to do
with me ain't got nothing to do with you
and they got nothing to do with our
mission for the [ __ ] week and the
mission is to swing dick and give our
[ __ ] firecrackers because we don't
give a [ __ ]
well what we're out what will [ __ ] 14
days away from [ __ ] jingle bells and
you're sitting there like a [ __ ] move
the law get up wash your [ __ ] shine
your shoes you can't sell a 10,000
dollar product with $10 [ __ ] shoes on
get out there mugger [ __ ]
you understand me sad I don't wanna hear
no excuses Joey which what the [ __ ] and
you've beaten you're on fire Elizabeth I
smoke a little reefer and then we'll
discuss the [ __ ] different avenues
that we have available to us Sacramento
I love you five sold-out shows you know
I went up on stage on [ __ ] edibles
shroom Tech and reefer like a [ __ ]
animal they should have drug tested me
after we know God knows or what happened
there you go but blowing it happy we got
two different weeds
we got the horse with no name from
perennial when we got the [ __ ]
hardcore OGS tanned me hardcore showed
the law you follow me - dum de dum doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
why Lance going through my mind
anyway it's [ __ ] Monday [ __ ]
whatever you were holding on to at the
door let it go [ __ ] it you're coming out
and [ __ ] shoot like a [ __ ]
cannonball you don't give a [ __ ] the
attitude heart and balls and you're not
taking no for a [ __ ] answer you
follow me yeah yeah yeah every time he
says no you take him down a different
Avenue I don't think so
we're gonna wait six weeks we'll listen
what's gonna happen in six weeks a
different from [ __ ] today you follow
me well that's what my wife gets a check
no problem
give me half down today and I'll take
the check and six [ __ ] weeks but
you're driving this [ __ ] to
anyway I just got a car salesman
flashback but no it's a sales flashback
you know why let me tell you something
[ __ ]
nobody told Led Zeppelin they were Led
Zeppelin Led Zeppelin told themselves
they will [ __ ] Led Zeppelin that's
what you're gonna do today
you're a bad [ __ ] you're sitting
at a little ho-hum you're I'm saying you
didn't get your [ __ ] balls breaking a
month and a half yourself confidence is
down who gives a [ __ ] brush your teeth
throw some water on your face powder
your balls and get out there you don't
give a [ __ ] that's the problem people
give a [ __ ] they feel like they go out
and they have a safety net they got a
hug from your mom gives a [ __ ] when you
ain't got a mom you don't have a [ __ ]
safety net and that's how you learn
about life that's how I learned about it
so get out there there ain't no [ __ ]
safety net get out they say no or you
and these young old a liar poppy or
SECAM ever won't come out being a legal
battle ah yo Jew of course I'm Tony oh
oh yeah sorry anyway a little [ __ ]
Spanish thing for you [ __ ] we
got a big day today I got a meeting
I got you Jitsu I got to do a [ __ ]
little strength training session and
then we got the [ __ ] podcast tonight
tip-top Magoo ready to go what I gotta
leave you hangin you know I love your
[ __ ] I just tuned in here
just to check up on you I'm like you
know today's your lucky day
you understand me today's the day you've
been waiting on everybody's always
waiting they hit the lottery the lottery
is within you the lottery is right
within you you don't know you don't go
down if you don't go somewhere and get
some [ __ ] dude two dollars and better
number but that's [ __ ] that that's a
[ __ ] mind [ __ ] the lottery is within
you got it right in let's do another
[ __ ] pie peel of the unknown soldier
you found me the horse with no name
everybody wants to bet the lottery you
wouldn't know what to do if you won with
the money anyway so what do you do a
[ __ ] the lottery is you [ __ ] bet on
you today the color dick [ __ ] today
that's my color only once your color
black or red my color is [ __ ] okay
that's the color of the [ __ ] day
ain't nobody [ __ ] stopping us I'm
with you you're with me and they want to
be with us you follow me
it's a boy that's a boy see you slow it
down what needs to be done comes into
focus and now [ __ ] they need a
battalion to [ __ ] stop me today cuz
I'm ready to strangle [ __ ] you
understand me and I hope you feel the
same way you got two weeks to Christmas
in that lay another week to [ __ ] sit
on the couch and decide what you're
gonna do and then it's 2018 listen if
you thought I thought I was gonna see
2018 when I was [ __ ] twenty you're
out of your mind
but I'm here I'm queer and I gotta
attack it like [ __ ] you know so I
suggest you do the [ __ ] same uncle
Joey here go out there today and even if
they say no ten times [ __ ] it you go
home you have a roast beef sandwich and
you ought to get on Tuesday and shove it
that dick down your [ __ ] throat again
on Tuesday and they might say no on
Tuesday and Wednesday that's your lucky
day when you're feeling down that's when
they're gonna say yes go get the [ __ ]
out there you follow me stop [ __ ]
around stop feeling sorry for yourself I
call that [ __ ] look at those people New
York waiting to [ __ ] get hit by a bomb
every [ __ ] morning you gotta walk
around New York with your head on a
swivel I got our ffensive linemen live
like a doctor
why run down there and [ __ ] one of them
when you could walk down and [ __ ] em all
and you know I'm saying dudes oh yeah
listen uncle Joey I'm gonna [ __ ] lie
to you you know I slept on them
trying to cut it on the [ __ ]
periscope hotline and [ __ ] they don't
know yeah I'm saying I've been there so
don't come to me with [ __ ] stories
don't come to me with no [ __ ] stories
pick yourself up it's a whole new
[ __ ] year
this year is a write-off you're not me
write offs I had 37 nobody was a bigger
loser than me and I went to bartending
school so but that your pipe is smoking
but here we are dropping [ __ ]
knowledge letting people know that
listen they're either gonna suck your
dick today or they're gonna suck it dick
in five years but eventually if you keep
throwing in that bat they're gonna suck
your dick that's what Harvey Weinstein
never knew that [ __ ] dummy he went
for the clothes right off the bat never
you just leave that dick out let the
wind blow and let the pieces fall where
they may and at the end of the day you
tried you [ __ ] anyway I got a
snap by the way I should enjoy that [ __ ]
on my [ __ ] plate I just wanted to
check in with you [ __ ] make
sure that you know that I [ __ ] love
you that without you [ __ ] I'd
have well gots but most importantly I
got you I got you you got me and then
like I said they're with us we're not
with them they're with us
remember nobody throws up when they was
up when they told themselves it was
simple and the rest is [ __ ] history
you follow me stay black grab your balls
kiss your mother and father tell them
you love them hug the [ __ ] animal and
get out there and don't take no for an
answer
tell him Juanita suck your dick ten
times over why did I keep repeating suck
my dick suck my dick and eventually
it'll suck your dick and they'll leave
me the [ __ ] alone and you can move on to
the next level of your [ __ ] life I'll
see you [ __ ] tonight
Churchill what's happening now stay
black uncle Joey loves you and don't
take [ __ ] from nobody today